[Music]
and we welcome you back to cbs this
morning you know moms are pretty well
represented at the tokyo games
at least a dozen team usa athletes have
children
from soccer star alex morgan to sprinter
allison felix
it's more common to see top women
competitors who have kids
but it hasn't always been easy to be a
mom and a champion janet chamlion
introduces us to a marathon runner
and a new mother alephine tuliamook who
helped push for a big change
at this year's games olympic marathoner
alephine tuliamook
thought nothing could surpass her love
of running
until january when she gave birth to her
daughter zoe
what have the last six months been like
for you becoming a mom
i just keep wondering like how was i
ever
normal and complete without my daughter
but the olympics without her daughter is
exactly what alephine was facing
after the international olympic
committee announced in march
breastfeeding moms could not bring them
to tokyo due to coveted protocols
a ruling that would impact allephene u.s
soccer player alex morgan
and a number of other athletes around
the world
it brokens my mind to think that in 2021
we are still telling mothers no if you
decide to be a mom
then you can't go to work the top
qualifying woman in the 2020 olympic
marathon trials faced an
unimaginable decision leave zoe behind
for 10
days or give up her lifelong dream
of going for gold it was such a
terrible choice to have to make as a
parent you know
everything that i do is a teaching
moment like
if i decided not to go what would i tell
zoe when she got older would i tell her
that i
didn't go to the olympics because i
wanted to be with her that's a lot to
put on a baby
elephant detailed her anguish on social
media alongside photos of breastfeeding
zoe
she and her partner tim decided to have
a baby after
last year's games were postponed
that she will run the olympic marathon
seven months after giving birth
is extraordinary determination that led
her to appeal to the head of the ioc
asking its decision be reversed soon
after
it was alephine and other moms could
bring their babies to tokyo
in her last days before heading to the
olympics we met alephine
at her training location in flagstaff
and it's a beautiful tumultuou
where she says she's doing some of the
best runs of her life
in between zoe's feedings
and delivering lessons she hopes will
someday inspire her daughter
i'm gonna go run i want her to know that
even when she's first the biggest
challenge of her life that
she can be resilient and she can do it
no matter where elephine finishes in
tokyo there can be little dispute
she's already a winner for cbs this
morning
i'm janet schamlian in flagstaff arizona
i have to say i think these olympic
games have really been a game changer
we're
talking less this olympics about like
heroes and strictly
and more about what it means to be human
right
and how beautiful we haven't done that
before yeah